in the Lexington herald-leader reports
on a Kentucky College students plea for
help after being targeted for
deportation by a classmate Paulo Garcia
who was in the daca program says another
student posted her Facebook profile
online along with a call to quote report
this illegal she says that that led to
harassment in her school refused to help
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with more on this
story Mike good morning good morning 21
year old Paola Garcia was born in
central Mexico her parents bought her to
this country when she was only two years
old she is politically active on her
college campus publicly opposing some of
the president's policies but now with
presidents from threatening to end the
program for immigrant children Garcia is
worried about eventual deportation my
name is Paulo Garcia a senior at
Transylvania University in an emotional
video posted to youtube 21 year old
Paola Garcia is concerned about her
future undocumented in a recipient of
daca Garcia says it was her undocumented
status that prompted fellow transylvania
university classmate taylor rag to
target her on social media rag appeared
to post this Facebook message over
Garcia's profile saying everyone go
report this illegal at my school
bragging about breaking the law he
incited others to harass me I mean he
took my personal information it's
blatant discrimination following RAK
social media post Garcia says she
received a number of hateful messages
from strangers she reached out to the
school but said her request for action
went unanswered I was told by them that
his actions did not violate school
policies because
only made a recommendation to his
readers about how to respond to my
undocumented status we're taking that
matter very seriously university
spokesperson Michelle Gaither sparks
would not comment on specifics but says
the school does not condone any type of
harassment
we absolutely 100% do not tolerate that
on our campus last week president Trump
announced the phasing out of dr. Jin
Congress to find a replacement in six
months this does not mean they are bad
people it means we are properly
enforcing our laws as Congress has
passed them president Trump said those
protected under daca have nothing to
worry about during the six-month period
Garcia says the university has shown her
support even offering to meet with both
Rag and her so far only garcia has met
with school officials CBS this morning
reached out to taylor rag for comment on
this story but have yet to hear back and
she came to this country she was only
two years old that is the very
definition of a dreamer
thank you very much flag